you don't have to do this  i'm a day trader i could just go home  you're good make it worth your while  take you to an atm  there's 14 grand in it everybody just  walks away  an atm  i know where the satchel is if you knew  you would have it with you  i could find it from the riverbank i  know where it is  i know something better what's that i  know what it's going to be  where's that it will be brought to me  and placed on my feet  you don't know too certainly  20 minutes it could be here i do know to  a certainty  and you know what's going to happen now  carson  you should admit your situation will be  more dignity in it  you go to hell  all right let me ask you something  if the rule you followed budget of this  of what yes was the rule  do you have any idea how crazy you are  you mean the nature of this conversation  i mean the nature of you  you you're gonna have the money  anton  [Music]  good  bye